- Gary if you could just wave
your hand above the glasses
and tell me what you feel.
- Nothing.
- That's the point.
- Okay.
- You see the middle of the glasses?
- I do.
- Watch, watch with me, you ready?
So looking in this area,
come from this side.
Yeah just look here, watch.
(upbeat music)
- How are you, I'm Gary.
- Thank you for having
us there, it's great.
- No worries.
- I actually, on the way
here I was on the elevator
and I wanted to ask you a question,
I'm gonna write something here.
- [Man] You got it.
- Because we're shooting this so...
- By the way thank God I
can't do this because I'd be,
I'd be the worst.
- Go straight to Gary,
Gary look at the camera
and tell us a two digit number,
whatever you want, just say something.
- One five.
- So it's 15.
- Yes.
- I wrote here Gary will say 15.
(laughter)
- I don't know what else to tell you.
- Do you see?
- I see it.
- Yes so why did you say
15, this is the question.
- Because you put it in my head.
- It's close to this,
it's close to this, yes.
Hi you guys, nice to meet you,
very awkward moment here but it's fun.
- It's fucking the best I--
believe in this shit
completely by the way.
- It's not about believing,
first of all it's about experiencing.
- Yes.
- I always say to people
it's not supernatural powers,
it's based on psychology or--
I'll ask you like a quick question
and try to go really fast.
Tell me the name of your first kiss.
- Kim.
- Kim okay so by saying this to you
this causes the entire
room to start thinking of,
see you start to think of the name,
and you think of the name.
- Yeah okay.
- And you think of the name
and you think of the name.
- Yep.
- Lindsay.
- [Lindsay] Mhmmm?
- I'm just looking at you right now,
let me tell you the process
just for clarification
you did not tell me the name.
- [Lindsay] True.
- Look at me, look at me, look at me.
Do you know the name of her first kiss?
- [Gary] No.
(Lindsay laughing)
- Okay so just--
- [Lindsay] That'd be weird if you did.
- Just think of it,
just think of a letter
in the middle of the name
but don't say it.
- [Lindsay] K.
- Okay you just had D.
(Lindsay laughing)
Can you, can you tape her for a second?
- Did you catch that?
(laughter)
- [Mentalist] You felt something
and I'm gonna write
something for you here.
- It's so impressive, right?
- [Mentalist] Now I swear
we don't know each other--
- I'm aware, we're not on stage here.
- [Mentalist] It just seems
to be very about this moment
that we don't know each other.
- By the way this is the best moment
that ever happened in my life.
- [Mentalist] Oh I love it.
- No no I'm being dead serious
this is the best moment of my life.
Like you have to understand
I love this so much
like you have to understand there's no,
there is no logical science
explanation for that
it's that you have to understand
I don't have this unfortunately
but I have something in
the way that I live my life
that is a cousin to this
that makes me understand its possibility.
- [Mentalist] Exactly.
- Like everything I say is
gonna happen to me happens.
- [Mentalist] I will say that
people think the universe
listens basically.
- I genuinely believe that man.
- [Mentalist] Hold this,
don't show her yet,
don't show her, I wrote
something over there.
What was your age when
you had your first kiss?
- [Lindsay] Uh, 13?
- [Mentalist] 13 so that's like...
- I'm impressed, very nice girl.
- [Lindsay] Thank you.
- [Mentalist] Look at
the camera dramatically.
- Oh man.
- [Mentalist] Yes and tell us the name.
- Aren't you gonna tell me the name?
- [Man] No, no, no, you tell the camera.
- [Mentalist] Just say the name.
- His name's Eddie.
- [Mentalist] Eddie? Can
you show her what I uh...
- It's so good, it's so good!
- It was a real kiss.
(laughs)
- Wait go back to me, go back to me.
So Eddie if you're
watching this right now--
It's fun, it's fun.
- I genuinely mean this.
I know that I don't,
again, I don't have this
but the reason I absolutely,
don't understand it, but
fundamentally understand
why we are blown away by this is
you just have a extreme different version
of something that I know
I'm living my life as
and so it makes sense,
I don't understand it
but but when I sell or when I talk,
when I interact with a human being,
I just know everything
that they're thinking.
Like I just know
everything that's going on.
- [Mentalist] So it's basically
the same process that I have
because I didn't know
how do I do what I do.
- Yes I understand.
By the way I get it, I
genuinely know what's going on.
- You thought of B by the way,
the letter B when she was thinking of,
yeah you had a B in your mind.
- No but by the way, by the way,
it's so interesting and the reason,
and the reason is seven years ago
I decided I would never get sick again.
I'm not gonna get sick ever again.
- [Mentalist] Unbelievable.
- I know it for fact.
- [Mentalist] Amazing.
- I don't wash my hands,
I travel 180 days a year,
I bite my fingernails.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm
not able to get sick.
I don't know what to tell you.
I just think that
we grossly underestimate
the brain in normal society.
- [Mentalist] That's the story of my life.
- Listen I get it so I understand.
I really genuinely do.
- [Mentalist] So it is great to meet you.
- It's great to meet you.
- I wish you could come
yesterday to the show.
- Can I, you'll like this.
When I was thinking my
number, five came to me
'cause it always does
it's my favorite number
but I was about to say something
and instead I said to 15.
- Boom, that was me influencing you.
- I know that.
I genuinely believe you.
I actually could feel it happen.
- Mhmmm, mhmmm.
- [Lindsay] I believe you.
- I know you guys know me
a little bit like I get it
I literally get it I was
trying to say something else
and it's amazing
I actually just am going
backwards right now
I was trying to say something else
and I was forced to say 15,
I'm telling you guys that's the truth.
- So I have to tell you something,
something that you'll love.
So I started--
- Can I harness this, like
I feel like, I feel like--
- Yeah first we came here
I saw people working outside
listen we need to arrange
a show here for everyone.
- Done.
- Blow their minds away.
When are you back in New York?
- I don't know yet but...
- Okay. Tyler make it happen,
we'll do a company wide event.
- Yes cool,
now second thing is because
you work with brands.
- [Gary] Yes.
- What I started to do, it
started as pure entertainment,
fun, getting people on
stage, get them blown away,
it became, it's still a one man.
- Yeah.
- My show is in this bag.
I have like office supplies
and stuff and I guess things
and it's a crazy paradoxes that happens
but then I start to invent something
so my invention's like infotainment.
Which means it's like a live commercial.
- I understand.
- On stage, I'll give
you a perfect example,
I did an event for Swatch
Group for their watch
and I brought five people on stage
and we stopped their watches completely.
Stopped them from working.
And everybody was oh my God oh my God
but there was one girl
that her watch kept moving
and I was going like what do
you have, I was acting like--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Something is wrong here.
- [Gary] Yeah of course.
- And like oh it's this
watch, no I can't stop it
and everybody was making fun
because basically we
remember the extraordinary,
that's what commercials are based on.
You will not remember
what you wore three weeks ago on Monday.
You don't remember,
but you remember exactly what
happened at 9/11 2001 exactly.
- [Gary] 100%, 100%.
- Because it was an experience for you.
So I create those oh moments and I
boom and I plug the
message of the company.
So in Germany I drove a car blindfolded
to say you can count on the
new BMW with your eyes closed.
So I create those crazy experiments,
it's fun to invent ideas for technology
if there's a company that's--
- I understand.
- Yeah it's a lot of fun.
So it involves a lot of creativity.
- So what's the punchline right now?
Like help me reverse engineer.
- [Mentalist] Okay.
- What are you excited about
in the short and long term?
- [Mentalist] Short term I'm
excited to perform, to perform.
- You love it. You live for it.
It's your oxygen.
- [Mentalist] It is.
- Okay keep going, I understand that.
- I love to perform,
I love the reaction, I
love to bring people.
- [Gary] What's better than that?
- Supposed to be a 15 minute show
ends up being 90 minutes
everybody's like--
- [Gary] I totally get it.
- It was fun.
Long term it's--
- [Gary] How much do you
care about your legacy?
- Oh that's a lot,
that's something new that
I started to think of.
That's very, very important for me.
- [Gary] Yeah, it should be.
- Yeah I just, did I
tell you about my dream?
I had-- I was talking to--
I have a lot of dreams
and thoughts about this
and I thought okay I know
my dad, my grandfather,
I remember his father but that's it.
So you don't remember
who was his dad, right?
And that's like 100 years,
that's it, that's nothing.
- That's what this is, my friend.
Right now, right now my
great, great, great,
great, great granddaughter
is watching this right now.
- [Mentalist] Or is if
we're talking about...
- So you know what I mean though?
- Of course.
- It's fucking cool.
But I'm, listen I wrote a
book about positive thinking
because I really believe in this,
the whole show is based on think positive
because you can never know
who's reading your mind
so control your thoughts,
that's what I do.
- [Gary] That's cool, that's clever.
- And I really love this concept
and I'm working with companies
and with individuals.
In the long term we'd be
keep doing exactly what I do
but going into the--
- From your perspective,
I mean I have a feeling of what you know
and I don't assume you know
everything about how I roll.
Do you feel as though what I feel
which is because I'm
good at communications
that I myself have more
awareness in the marketplace
than like I should be the one that says it
that I deserve because I'm
good at that and that that,
I know what you're doing,
you're just putting people together.
- You figure out a way to
say okay here are people,
here are products and services.
- Yes.
- [Man] And how do you
get the message across
where everybody today you look
everyone's looking at this device,
no one's looking at billboards,
no one's sitting there
looking at magazine ads
and things like that,
television commercials,
people fast forward.
So coming up with ways to
take products and services
and your big thing which
I've read your books,
come up with a good product and service.
- Yes and you just think
this is an amazing product.
- And he is who he is
and I know you're working
with all these companies
doing what you do,
he's working with all these
companies that do what you do
and put two people in a room and say okay.
- I just think I'm a very good weapon,
to say weapon in front of
companies or individuals.
- [Gary] I get it.
- So today do maybe some fun
interesting things that--
- [Gary] How do you categorize yourself?
- I am a mentalist, a master mentalist.
- [Gary] Master mentalist.
- Yes, yes.
- [Gary] And who's the
number one master mentalist
in the world?
And does the world believe that?
- Depends who you ask.
- [Gary] Cool.
- The only problem is...
- If I ask 7.8 billion people,
who would be number one?
- They won't know how to tell you.
They will say David Copperfield.
- I think you're right,
I think you're right.
Can I ask you a real selfish question?
- [Mentalist] Always.
- Do you want them to say you?
I mean it.
And I need you to--
- [Mentalist] The only thing is
I love when this 1% of the
population, South Arabian prince.
- Yeah.
- King of Thailand just passed away.
- Yeah I saw, 88 years old, go ahead.
- I did a performance for
him and all those people
so it's like 0.1% of this
population knows about me.
Those specific people.
- The people that can afford
to have you do private
things at their home.
- Yes.
- [Gary] Go ahead.
- Sometimes I want to go to mass public,
sometimes I don't want too much because...
- [Gary] You like your life?
- That's why I'm expensive,
that's why I'm like...
- [Gary] I understand.
- That's why I don't have
managers and people it's like--
- [Gary] I understand.
- Very boutique.
- [Gary] You'd much rather do
seven events at a million dollars each
than 59 events to do
seven million dollars.
- I would do two.
- I understand.
Would you?
Because if you really do love to perform
you wouldn't do two.
Your business head would do two.
- [Mentalist] No no,
business wise I would do two.
- I understand, I would, I would--
- I would do 30 charity events supporting,
using my connections.
- [Gary] I understand.
- Using stuff like that.
But to make a living
I would do the minimum
and then focus...
- On other things.
Other things.
- On cool cool things, yes.
- But you're also, he's
got two children and all,
Tel Aviv based, he's on a
plane probably 180 days a year.
- [Mentalist] 176, he's more.
- 177 for me.
I wrote it down right here.
(laughter)
- Oh my god!
- So those are things where just
I'd like to be able to see for him
I always thought of having him
let's say in New York City Broadway.
- I would do this, you
know what's so funny?
Like by the way the most
interesting part of this was
I was literally able to feel
me being forced to say it.
- [Mentalist] Yeah, yeah.
- Do a lot of people get that?
- [Mentalist] Not a lot.
- That's why I feel like I got something
'cause I actually, I mean it.
- [Mentalist] It's
sensitive, very sensitive.
- I'm the most sensitive.
- [Lindsay] We know. (laughs)
- No really, it's real.
- You know what?
- I'm stealing your phone here Gary.
- Xander, Xander--
Okay no problem.
Xander is showing it.
- You have a password?
- [Lindsay] Really?
- Yes. Yes.
- Okay I know it's password, it's fine.
- Yes.
(laughter)
- [Lindsay] You think he's
more sensitive than you?
- [Gary] I don't know
and actually you know
that'd be one place where
I wouldn't be competitive,
that would make me happy
'cause I think it's special.
- Okay so you need to
change your password.
- [Gary] No problem.
- It's a fun game, fun game.
You press a two digit number.
- [Gary] Two digit?
- Two digit, put it in
one, just do that tip tip.
And you press plus.
- Kay.
- [Mentalist] And what you
do, don't think about it.
- Okay, yep.
- Just use your intuition it's very fun.
If this works I will be in shock.
You keep going, is it 91?
- Yes.
- You already did plus plus, right?
- I hit plus, yes.
- Okay so one more number,
like two digits again.
- Two digits again?
- And plus again
and you keep doing it
like different numbers.
- Keep going?
- Yes, two digits, boom
plus, two digits, plus,
and just can you go faster?
- Yes.
- Just tap, tap, tap,
plus, da da da da very good
and now go to three digits.
Da da plus da da da plus stop.
Divide.
- Divide?
- Two digit number. Equal. Score?
- Five two one oh nine.
- Crazy.
That's your number yeah
that's your number.
- That's my number?
- Yep.
That's 52901, 52109?
(laughter)
- So great!
- No but you know what's
special about 52901,
I say it's your number
yes it's your number Gary,
it's G, A, and R, and Y.
(laughter)
- Her face is...
I fucking love it, I
believe in it the most
and when I tell you,
when I tell you that my
interest in magic when I was--
- Don't call it magic.
- Respect, but like my
interest level in this,
zero interest in believing. Zero.
It's all practical,
I just know it's real, I know
it's real, I know it's real.
- [Man] It's amazing stuff though.
- No it's the craziest shit of all time
are you fucking kidding
me, like the craziest shit
but I understand so listen I,
I could do this the rest of my life.
Here's what I would say
because I think my intuition is
you also understand the way I understand.
I think I can really help
I just need to be able to reverse engineer
and I wanna help, it's
where I'm most comfortable.
- That's why we're here.
I have to tell you something
and to be completely completely honest,
we did some very cool projects,
very very cool things,
some of them are big
some of them are small,
I'll tell you a little bit one project
I got a phone call three months
ago from Barbara Streisand
and she said listen we're doing a tour,
do you wanna do a show with me?
So obviously say yes,
now my show is not
designed for 20,000 people.
- [Gary] Sure.
- So I had to invent ideas
and it worked perfectly.
- [Gary] Of course.
- It was so much fun and--
- Well it's important to let you--
Barbara was singing and you
had Barbara part of the show.
- Yes, yes.
- She didn't leave the
stage and do a thing.
- We do all this stuff and it's fun
but most of it we're doing
scattered and just creating
oh let's do this let's do this or this
and I think you could
help us be more like,
with ideas and be more
organized or create something.
- [Gary] I think so too.
- Because what do you
do in the social media?
You don't really do anything
other than Facebook?
- Yeah.
- You know what?
It's better than that.
It's a top line strategy
reverse engineering the
reality of what you want.
- I'm a no tech person, you know?
- That's okay, me too.
- Because even in the shows
by the way a mentalist,
I cannot go on a show and
start doing screens and stuff
because people will think technology.
I have to go with a chalkboard
and write stuff down
and show people that it's
authentic, that it's real.
Do you have glasses?
This is the grand finale, sunglasses.
- [Gary] No.
- [Man] Up there.
- [Lindsay] Oh on your shelf.
- Yeah but I get it,
see I'm not using mine
and I need you to come over here
and do a over the shoulder
shot and you come here
and I want you to, we'll put over here,
come come come, and your first
kiss kind of a weird name.
- [Man] Yeah it's a super weird name.
- Like where is she from?
- She...
- She lives in America.
- Last name would not be American, no.
It was a last name.
- Oh a last name, oh
really, whoa like Ebel?
Ibel, Ebel?
- Is that where it's from you're asking?
- No the name is close, am
I close? What's the name?
- Yeah, a little bit. Tabey.
- Tabey, oh okay, I
was close, I was close.
- [Man] You had the B.
- Exactly.
Gary, just wave your
hand above the glasses
and tell me what you feel.
- Nothing.
- That's the point.
- Okay.
- You see the middle of the glasses?
- I do.
- Watch, watch with me, you ready?
You watching, you watching?
So looking, and camera
come from this side.
Just look here.
- Yeah I just, you know.
(laughter)
It's the best, but...
- I love it.
- [Lindsay] How much
strength does that take?
- Oh it's a lot it's
like working in a gym.
- No way.
- Yes.
- It was a piece of cake for him.
- No no no no for me after
like I wanna do a few acts
and I'm starting to sweat and--
- So listen so I think so
Tyler we need to obviously run.
Get us together.
Let me like, I wanna actually,
this is not something I wanna rush.
Look, I get, I don't think
like this all makes--
I'm gonna say something,
this makes more sense to me
than anybody you've ever met in your life.
Now what I need is a little bit more time
to get you into a place for what I do well
in a comfortable place
so I can really help you.
- We love it.
- Great.
- [Man] Well I want it to be mutually
like whatever it is you do I mean--
- He just did this,
he just did this thing I
mean this was enough, 52109.
52109 is like my number, no 100%.
- [Mentalist] There you go, there you go.
- And I think, and this
is kind of back to like
versions of the same game,
I'm only most comfortable
in providing val--
like it's all gonna be, like
I don't know any other move
and the same way he can
flip fucking glasses
like I'm not interested in what--
I don't have that gear.
I don't know what's in it
for me, I know I wanna do it.
- [Man] Okay.
- Like do you understand?
- [Man] I get it, alright.
- Really cool, my friend,
great to meet you.
- I enjoyed that very much.
- Have to give you a hug, I'm a hugger.
- Me too.
- Alright.
- Good to see you brother.
- It was good.
- I enjoyed that.
- Thank you so much brother
thank you for having us.
- And is LA or New York
or any city that I know?
- I prefer New York.
But I love Tokyo.
(laughter)
I mean it's fun, it's fun.
I say quietly to Mike that
I prefer New York to LA.
Let's do it.
- It's my cool picture.
- [Man] Good stuff, cool.
- Alright.
- I need to feel the short
term and the long term
and then I can really do some stuff.
- Okay.
- We'll figure it out.
And arrange something because
I wanna freak all of you out.
- I will, we'll, you know
what, that's what we'll do,
why don't we arrange something right away
for a company event
and then we'll spend the hour
and a half after we'll talk.
I mean here's the punchline.
Why Lindsay's here is
we're building something
that is the future of all this
which is what D Rock's doing.
It's a human production company
and I don't need to sell it,
I need to show it to you guys
and then we'll figure out what that means.
- I just had fun with it.
- Yeah okay.
- I had a blast thanks
for taking your time.
- Of course great to see
you have a great day.
(upbeat music)